[Music]
Democrats rightly attack Republicans
when they promise their math defying tax
cut plans will slash government revenue
but somehow not balloon deficits
well what tax cuts are Republicans
single-payer health care seems to be for
Democrats a populist policy idea that's
far more attractive in theory than
practice Bernie Sanders Medicare for all
plan is the perfect example recall that
economists sharply criticized his
presidential campaigns health care plan
for severely under estimating the cost
of the benefits it offered it turned out
the taxes needed to pay for Bernie care
we're twice as high as estimated his
plan would also phase out employer
provided health care even though some
seventy percent of workers in those
plans say they're satisfied with the
coverage in other words the Sanders plan
failed to recognize either economic or
political reality similar to many
Republican tax cut promises the economy
is doing pretty well right now so now is
hardly the time to gamble on
ill-considered populist schemes from the
left or right how about this instead
stabilize Obama care reform the tax code
to encourage more domestic investment
and do both in a bipartisan fiscally
responsible way to learn more about my
take on Medicare check the links in the
description below also let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI